- All right, I wanna close things out
with one more highlight
from our season four premier road trip.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
Two weeks ago, we rolled
into New York city,
with our recording studio on wheels
to kick off our search
for the country's greatest
undiscovered voices.
That first day was filled
with excitement and surprises.
Our friends at the "Today"
show got in on the fun as well.
They featured some people in the crowd,
waiting to sing on our Kellyoke bus.
But one guest, an aspiring
singer named Jade,
had no idea I was there.
It was awesome.
(swooshing)
♪ Since you've been gone ♪
(audience applauds)
♪ I can breathe for the first time ♪
♪ I'm so moving on, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Thanks to you ♪
♪ Now I get ♪
♪ I get what I want ♪
(audience applauds)
(Jade screams)
I am totally stealing that
run, that run, I was like...
(Kelly screams)
I walked out, I was like,
"Wait, what was so good".
(audience applauds)
I love a good surprise,
when I am the one doing the surprising.
We have Jade on the line right now.
What's up, Jade?
(audience applauds)
- Hi, everybody, hi, Kelly.
- It's great to see you again.
So, was it a good surprise?
- A good surprise?
(Kelly laughs)
A great surprise, actually.
- [Kelly] Well, wait, well...
- [Jade] It was such a
special moment, Kelly.
I remember when I was younger,
my parents got me a karaoke
machine with one singular CD
and it literally, the first song on the CD
was "Stronger" by Kelly Clarkson.
- Yes.
- [Jade] And just to know
that you are a part of
some of my earliest memories in music,
is just so special to me.
And the moment I will cherish forever,
especially when you complimented my run.
(audience laughs)
- Oh, I'm not lying either, I'm taking it.
I was like, "Oh, okay,
wait, that was really nice".
Well, I, we got to talk a little bit,
but everybody else doesn't know
like, your like, you know, aspiration.
So, tell everybody what you wanna do.
- Right, so, right now I'm in an era
where I'm really finding myself in music.
I'm actually studying classical
music at NYU right now.
- Wow.
- So, I really appreciate you
as a cross genre vocalist,
shout out to the Kellyoke album.
Not a lot of people can
go from "Blue Bayou"
to "Call Out My Name".
Shout out to you for that.
(Jade chuckles)
- [Kelly] Oh, my God, love you.
You're making me feel really
good about myself, what?
(audience chuckles)
But you know what, you would know though,
like if you learn, if
you're classically trained
it is easier to kind of, you know,
be fluid through different genres
and we all love all
different kinds of music.
- Right, yeah.
I definitely agree with that.
And as we spoke before, I
mentioned to you that I'd love
to be a music educator.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, just to spread
the joy that I have of music
with other people, especially
with younger people,
it would just make me
feel so accomplished.
So, very appreciative for you.
- I love you, Jade.
(audience applauds)
I love you so much.
I'm so glad that we met
and I'm liking your post
right now, right, ma'am?
(bell rings)
- [Jade] Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- All right, well that's not all,
our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pen
of the "Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable people,
just like you, ma'am,
so they're gonna write you a check
for $1,000 to aid in
whatever you wanna do.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, my goodness, oh, my God.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
Good luck, Jade.
We love you at the "Kelly Clarkson Show"
and thank you to all
of our guests this hour
and to each and every person
who made this two-week premier road trip
utterly spectacular, thank you.
It has been an amazing time
and there're so many
more good times to come
throughout all of season four.
So, keep on watching, everybody.
Meanwhile, have a great
day and a great weekend
and if not, well, try and change it.